i'm sorry i've seen a bunch of videos
from you know these like leftists on
twitter
where they walk around a wealthy area
showing the ice cream shops and then say
new york is totally fine everything's
normal stop watching fox news
i i you know i i walk around new york
city i'm the guy on the street
i'm gonna tell you of of of empty stores
of closed
doors of people getting fined of of
houses that are sitting
vacant for not months for years
people can't move into their own homes
that they work so hard to renovate or
build
uh they're getting fake stop work orders
you know what a stop work order is the
inspector comes in well you built an
extra wall
you didn't follow the plan you're not
conforming stop work order just like
that
and nobody could work or we're vacating
you because your grandmother is living
down in the basement
when you're only allowed to have a couch
and a tv but you put a bed down there
it's illegal
vacate your house it sounds like they're
destroying new york on purpose i mean i
said it before but
all of these stories everything i've
seen when you look at the riots it
happened in june
and then you see the uh the i believe it
was the assistant district attorney he
started cutting loose
the lower level uh you know misdemeanor
charges
they've done this all over it it feels
like you've got
you know what let me let me start over i
think earlier this year we had a very
serious problem we had
we had uh a couple hospitals in new york
had that were overflowing they brought
in the trucks
we we didn't see the javits center
completely full but there are people you
know in there
i think we completely panicked we
overreacted
but but but in initially i'm not too
upset that we overact
overreacted in the beginning because we
did have a very serious problem spike
and a lot of deaths
now it seems like something's different
they're saying hospitalizations are up
coveted cases are up and the amount of
deaths are going up
and it feels like everything they did
early on didn't work
they're just going to do the same thing
over again but what i really think
is that they're exploiting it you've got
politicians who've realized they can use
it
to gain whatever they want because we
run the risk of getting banned on
youtube simply
simply by questioning or talking about
it or bringing these things up
i got a story here it's from john
hopkins university published a study
the researcher compared the previous
years the total
the average deaths in the u.s and found
that the average deaths this year
are almost no different the interesting
thing though is that
heart disease deaths were way down and
cova deaths were way up
and they concluded in this uh article
that they believe that kova deaths were
being over exaggerated their words
i could get banned for just bringing the
story up the story gets deleted
terrible without without notice now if
you bring the story up they say it's
fake news
the researcher stands by it saying no i
pulled the publicly available research
compared the date the the the
information and they say
it's fake news if you bring that up
you're right and i want you to know if
you would look at last year's death
though and you don't have to check with
me you don't have to believe me
you can go to the cdc or to the health
department january
february this year and last year were
identical deaths
throughout you get it to the funeral
pals there's a special website for it
correct march april may and june we went
up 25 000
uh additional deaths in new york city
again panic
uh fake numbers whatever it is but yeah
25 000 more during
the compared to the year before july
august september
october have matched last year now i
don't know how you're telling me there's
more cover death
but the same death rate is now the same
as last year's
death certificates remember each death
certificate is numbered so you can't
trick the city
so the numbers are the same i don't know
where spike second wave was supposed to
hit us in july
second wave august september october
it's november so far no second wave
one out of every 300 000 people that die
from covet
is under the age of 65. most of them are
above 65 so you have to take care of
your seniors but we can't take care of
our seniors because we're not making
money
and they have nowhere to eat nowhere to
go and if you noticed
they're going out because they have no
choice do you remember when de blasio
said he wanted to buy
up the buildings yeah so they they they
force having to shut down they get rid
of tourists they destroy the economy and
then
property value tanks because people are
evicted and kicked out bill de blasio
says you know i think we'll buy them and
turn them into
buy then we can take them take them yeah
yeah you know he wants to distribute the
wealth
we've been wealthy too long so it's now
time to share
this is what he says you hear it you
don't have to listen to me listen to his
news conference
we have to take the wealth we've been
wealthy for the last 40 years it's time
that we equal everything out take the
wealth from the wealthy and give it
to other people is he really is he
really normal mentally ill i mean
there's something wrong with him you
just can't do it well i mean he can be a
communist doesn't mean he's mentally ill
i think that's mentally ill but
everybody in the chat is going to say
yes
yes but he thinks he can take away our
properties
he thinks we're all going to leave and
and just do whatever he wants i'm not
going to let him do it
i'm standing yes i'm the one guy right
now standing in his way
and i'm going to get to city council i'm
hoping he'll be gone i know he'll be
gone
i'm gonna clean sweep the city council
with a bunch of good people and if not
you're gonna see me stop them i'm gonna
filibuster them i'm not gonna let them
get away with it
you know i don't know if you like aoc or
not
another witch not a big fan right so she
we had amazon came into new york city
promised us 25 billion dollars listen to
me people
there's more actually over time right
now right but
also you keep forgetting the housing
that was going to get built around there
another 10 billion dollars the
trickle-down jobs 10 billion dollars the
taxes from these people
plus all the new work that would have
come up all all
thrown out why because she was in one of
her moods to show it bill de blasio and
governor cuomo chickened out they loved
the idea
you're talking what we could have done
the housing the jobs that were going to
come in
i i don't know where my politicians were
saying okay if you don't want it in long
island
come to brooklyn we all want it the
trickle-down jobs just in my
neighborhood would have been in the tens
of millions of dollars
cuomo actually ragged on aoc for that
aoc
would you let her get away with it well
yeah so so uh she ended up saying that
she had nothing to do with it it wasn't
even in my district
and she actually was correct it wasn't
enough she had no right to open her
mouth
but she was leading protests she was one
of the keynote speakers at a protest in
the financial district saying
that amazon shouldn't come in and man i
tell you
she came out and said why are we giving
amazon three billion dollars because she
didn't understand that a discount isn't
giving someone money right so so
the controversy here i don't know you're
i don't know if you're familiar with oh
no tertiary
so so basically you freak out when you
hear this so the city said
we're going to give you a tax break if
you build your headquarters here not
money not money not money a tax break
but there would be rebates and grants
and stuff that would come along with it
basically
if you generate 30 billion dollars in
tax revenue for the city over 10 years
we'll cut off 10 of that so she
actually gave an interview where she
said why are we giving them three
billion dollars that logic
as if it's not logic by the way there
was that was
there there were some grants there were
some rebates there was some money that
would come from the city
but it was in the event that amazon set
up an hq it was an incentive it was it
was 25 to 40
000 jobs correct and and listen to me 25
to 40 000
new jobs forget all the other outer jobs
all the new houses all the new consumers
everything everything one of the
businesses that's flourishing in this
crisis right now amazon
yeah sorry to interrupt continue please
this would have been new housing that
would
that would be built new maintenance for
the housing there would be a lot more
commerce and economic exchange in these
areas bodegas
oh i love you and she she led protests
because it just fit the narrative big
corporation amazon bad and hey you know
what honestly
i'm down with that narrative because
amazon is profiting like crazy while all
the small businesses are being destroyed
and it's people like cuomo and de blasio
a new sum and all these other governors
and people like pelosi
who break the rules destroy the small
businesses for everybody else while the
big box stores and big corporations make
sweet cash
but i understand there's a difference
and sometimes you're going to say
it would be nice if we had 25 to 40 000
new jobs because i don't know the the
mta in new york is collapsing
right the cities are the trains are
falling apart they're i remember when
they said they were gonna shut down the
l train between williamsburg and
manhattan and it caused a panic in the
in the housing market
and so they need money to fix this stuff
she decides she's gonna lead a protest
once it comes out that she's destroyed
jobs and everyone's mad she goes
that wasn't me i don't live in that
district and all of a sudden it was like
d do you not remember when we were
criticizing you because you led this
protest in the financial district is new
york gonna give amazon 3 billion no no
no no no it was a discount it was a
discount yeah it's like it's like
i mean it's a rebate right if not no no
threshold they were going to give them
no there were some rebates there was
some instances where they would provide
cash but it was all contingent upon
if you have a company here if you have
these jobs if you're generating
billions in tax revenue then we give you
money over time no you pay less in taxes
pay less taxes
so we're not giving you anything but
just a discount yeah it was a three
billion dollar discount
there was a small amount that would have
been rebates but
that's not negligible i'm just pointing
it's on money already made accrued
so that's not like right right exactly
so so it would be like
the analogy she claims is that you go to
a you know like a
you know i don't know pizza store pizza
restaurant and they say
you know one dollar off pizza and then
she thinks the pizza the guy the stop
hands the customer the dollar and then
he leaves
no it means if you want to buy a large
pizza it's nine dollars instead of ten
dollars
he's not gonna give you a dollar and
then you leave dude i think we have a
lot of lazy politicians right now
do nothing dumbbells that don't they
don't even read the bills
how can you i think it should be firstly
of that a policy should not be allowed
to vote on a bill if they don't read it
and they should swear under oath that
they read the thing i love you know what
i
you know i i'm gonna like that you know
i love that idea i never even thought it
brilliant
swear underwriter right away that you
read the whole bill and you um you don't
even have to understand at least you
read it
not one of your work is ready you know
our trains he was saying about the mta
they cleaned the trains at nighttime
getting rid of covert which
the next day the first person that
touches it gets it back do you know how
rat infested the mta is
ratchet i mean just come if you want to
have a good lap just stand sometimes
okay all over the place now now that uh
the lockdowns have been for for a long
time rats are roaming the streets and
packs
this is the crazy thing with all these
lockdowns there's no more people
dropping food giving food
so it's actually happening in a bunch of
cities all over the world there's one
crazy video where there's baboons
and they're forming street gangs because
there's no tourists would throw them
food right
now there's nobody so when someone drops
you know an ice cream they all start
fighting each other over it in gangs
in new york this is crazy packs of rats
run down the street and they chase
people he's not joking no it's real
yeah yes because they used to get the
scraps there's so many people everywhere
dropping scraps the rats were fat and
happy
now they're starving and they're
becoming desperate and they'll chase you
like big too
yeah but they're packs it's crazy wow
and i want to go on another subject with
you guys
this is something that really bothers me
we have a homeless issue
and when you were saying about the
hotels before mayor de blasio
spent his wife that's why i got in
trouble i i didn't know you're allowed
not to call a woman
a bad thing well you shouldn't call
people names
okay well that's who i am you know what
i mean she stole i mean she lost 1.25
billion dollars i'm gonna call her the
name well
so she was part of a committee which is
not even an elected official
he put him in charge of the mental
health issue 1.25 billion dollars was
lost
disappeared now first of all let me tell
you as a contractor i can build sixteen
hundred homes
i can house over uh time that by eight
by the way i could put eight people in a
home i can do that
put them house them not apartments not
little homeless shelters if you ever go
to homeless shelter they're disgusting
and i've been to many of them to visit
and help them get approved
homes that we can put them in i have 69
000 homeless people on the street
forget about that they're no good
they're bams they're whatever you want
to talk about about them i don't know
why people would even
degrade them some of them are lost you
have 20 thousand of them that are
children
twenty thousand of my homeless kids are
children sleeping on the street
i don't have much money i go on the
street once a week i try to give out two
dollars five dollars i get a lot of
clothing donations a lot of people get
it but my friends give me good stuff
some nice leftover jacket or stuff for
the kids and i give it out wherever i
could and on friday i do my two three
hours
and they're so happy and when mary de
blasio took them off the street and put
them in a hotel
you know what i mean and now since he
says covert is restricted right we all
have to be in their homes
what about the 69 000 people on the
street that are not spreading the
disease
you're putting them back in homeless
shelters so they're not spreading the
disease
again it doesn't make sense his whole
reaction i asked him make me mayor
make me deputy mayor i will come up with
the covet answer which i
will put all the communities together
i'll get leaders from every community
i'll threaten them i'll scream at them
i'll create an independent coalition
go from door to door in each of our
communities work with our people come up
with ideas
and solve the problem thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you